let's talk today for a while about how
governments can and should deal with
recessions this is an important question
right now the unemployment rate is
skyrocketing more than 20 million people
2024 23 million people have lost their
jobs in the last five weeks we learned
today that GDP was down almost 5 percent
in the first quarter of the year we are
seeing some ideas that second quarter
GDP could be down as much as 20 percent
or even more so we have a serious
situation here recession depression and
we need to think about what are the
options for what governments can do what
has Trump done and is he doing a good
job or isn't he doing a good job and
what I want to suggest to you today is
that given the circumstances
Donald Trump has actually used most of
the correct measures that are available
under the paradigm of Keynesian
economics to deal with the recession but
he's done it in a completely incompetent
crony and slow way and these are
policies that are direct contradictions
to what Republicans claim are the
policies that a government should
institute so there's also an element of
hypocrisy but we'll get to that so to
start with governments have two major
sets of sort of tools at their disposal
monetary policy and fiscal policy and
very simply when we say fiscal policy we
mean government spending to influence
the economy and when we say monetary
policy we're talking about treasury
management in our case it's whoever
manages the currency treasury management
of the money supply and of interest
rates so fiscal policy would include
things like spending on infrastructure
during a recession to create jobs hire
businesses to fix bridges the businesses
pay those employees that are doing the
work those employees then go and spend
that money in the economy helping the
grocery store and the landscaping
company than higher and higher and so on
and so forth so that's fiscal policy
then you've got monetary policy monetary
policy would be for example cutting
interest rates
to encourage loans making loans cheaper
so that people will go and borrow money
with which they can pay for expenses buy
things maybe pay employees etc when
coronavirus hits
businesses start to close people stop
traveling a bunch of things happen
without government intervention that
aren't good
this increases unemployment naturally
there's a demand collapse people stop
going to restaurants so the restaurant
no longer needs their workers so they
lay them off which means the restaurant
owner isn't making any money they can't
pay their rent or maybe they can't pay
their utilities so that affects their
landlord the restaurant doesn't have
customers so it doesn't need to buy food
so they stop spending with the food
supplier the food supplier doesn't need
to buy as much stuff from farmers the
farmers no longer need as many employees
I think you can sort of understand that
now the the food what example is a more
interesting one because you see a demand
reduction at restaurants but an increase
at grocery stores but as we've learned
with toilet paper oftentimes the
personal and commercial supply chains
for some of these goods are separate so
that's sort of a detail but I think you
generally understand the the idea here
the other thing that can happen in a
recession is that you get a deflationary
spiral so in the same way that if
everybody wants hand-sanitizer the price
of sanitizer gets driven up up up which
we saw about seven eight weeks ago
if for example nobody's driving around
this leads to a drop in oil and gasoline
prices which we've seen now we may not
care that much about oil prices being
low it sounds intuitive that lower
prices are just good right I mean if
we're in a recession and stuff costs
less that's good it means people can
afford more of it the problem is that it
can cause more unemployment if you run a
business and suddenly not only do people
want less of your stuff but you have to
lower the price because people aren't
willing to pay as much for it that
further is not being able to keep
employees on so you lay people off which
means they don't have money to buy stuff
which means
the deflation continues that's why it's
called a spiral in a healthy economy you
might see some deflation because we get
better at making something so if we
become much more efficient at making a
particular product we lower our cost to
make each one of those items and as
companies compete with each other
whoever can increase productivity and
lower costs can maybe gain more market
share so that's okay that's a good
example of prices coming down
deflation deflationary spirals in a
recession aren't good so let's now look
at the things Donald Trump has done or
things that that have been done if not
by Donald Trump personally so the Fed
cut interest rates great
that's monetary policy that's the right
thing to do
the Treasury has created these PPP
programs paycheck protection plan
programs where the interest rate is its
effect effectively negative you get
money and as long as you use it for the
right things the loan doesn't have to be
paid back in full
that's the correct thing to do now the
problem is they did it in the crony
capitalist way that Trump always seems
to do it took too long there were all
sorts of logistical failures the system
didn't actually start distributing money
for a month or longer money ran out too
quickly a lot of the money went to
really large corporations and other
institutions instead of small businesses
small businesses ended up not being able
to get money Trump has to scramble ask
for more money and ask for money back
total disaster in its implementation but
it is policy that makes sense now
there's a practical way in which PPP is
kind of a blend of monetary and fiscal
policy it's sort of like low interest
loans which is monetary but forgivable
loans to business are sort of like
government spending which is fiscal
policy but that that's kind of a detail
in terminology another important
monetary policy component is
expectations management this is part of
why remember we talked last week or the
week before we get bad unemployment news
and yet the stock market sometimes goes
up what's going on
managing expectations is part of
monetary policy you tell the public in
advance what you expect to see happen so
that it more smooth this is the goal
right it more smoothly gets priced into
the markets and then when the news hits
it's not a shock to the system because
the markets were expecting it anyway
that is a form of monetary policy
expectations management so let's now
talk about fiscal stimulus you can do
fiscal stimulus by cutting taxes so when
Trump proposed it didn't happen but
Trump proposed what if we do a waiver or
a moratorium on the payroll tax until
the end of the year that would be a form
of fiscal stimulus through a tax cut you
can also do fiscal stimulus by the
government spending money this can be
buying things this can be hiring
companies to do stuff it can also be
just the government sending people
checks could be a one-time payment which
we've seen could be by increasing
unemployment benefits what we're talking
about is deficit spending there are sort
of people on the right who like to
cartoon áfive this as printing money we
talked last week with stephanie kelton
about that calling it printing money is
not really an accurate term what we're
talking about is deficit spending we're
talking about digitally adding money to
people's accounts now again Trump is
doing this he's boosting unemployment
benefits
that's fiscal policy it's getting money
to people which people can then spend
increasing aggregate demand maintain
prices relatively level more level than
they otherwise would be when Trump cuts
$1,200 checks or really the Treasury
does that's fiscal policy it's
government spending now they also sent
billions to some industries airlines
cruise companies that's also fiscal
stimulus and it is the right tool but
the problem has been again
implementation took way too long
not nearly enough money for the average
individual a ton of the spending was
done with companies that really
shouldn't be the priority should have
been more money for individuals we heard
last week from billionaire investor
Chamath Polya Padilla who said that you
know some of the companies being bailed
out these are really bailing out these
are bailouts of the billionaires who are
speculating not the employees if you
really want to bailout employees you can
do it in a much more direct way in
addition Trump has done it in a
completely a crony capitalist way he's
reduced oversight which has turned some
of these bailout funds into essentially
slush funds he's used government money
to buy things like ventilators and PPE
that stimulus except there's always
something weird when Trump does it like
the company that is bankrupt with no
employees which has gotten a big
contract to essentially just middleman
the purchase of a bunch of masks way
above market value so it's the right
tool it's being done in a crony
capitalist way the focus is often wrong
it took forever millions have still got
nothing the univer the unemployment
insurance supplements have still not
been received by a lot of people
so in short Donald Trump has used the
right tools under the Keynesian paradigm
and I'll talk more about that in a
second fiscal policy monetary policy but
he's done it in an incompetent way and
it of course is of course massive
hypocrisy because what we hear from the
right year in and year out is one we
don't have the money for this that's
clearly untrue we found it right and
it's again it's not really finding it
that's a misnomer but we were able to do
it
despite Republicans saying it's not
possible so there's the hip-hip-hip
Icarus II element and number two
you often hear Republicans saying that
these types of techniques don't actually
work and yet here they are saying hey
we've actually got to do it so
incompetence and hypocrisy but the right
tools have been used now what hasn't
Trump done that he could have done
infrastructure spending Trump has talked
about doing infrastructure spending it
would be important to do six solid
months of infrastructure spending so
have the government spend on fixing
roads bridges tunnels the electric grid
could be bolstered water supply could be
better protected there's tons of things
that could be done they would boost
employment they would inject money and
when we come out of this whenever it is
we would be better prepared we would
have better infrastructure to resume all
of that economic
activity it's not been done it's time to
do it from should have already gotten
this going
he talks maybe it'll happen in the next
phase we don't know that certainly has
been a mistake now let's zoom out from
all of this why everything I've been
talking about these fiscal policy tools
these are what we call Keynesian tools
they're from the school of fiscal policy
founder John Maynard Keynes our
government has these tools available
instead of other tools because Keynesian
economics are sort of the orthodoxy and
this is based on you see a recession
fundamentally as a demand shortage and
you then take these reactions of fiscal
policy that we've described that is not
the only way to see the role of
government before and during a recession
or or a depression a more progressive
economic worldview would say all right
David you've accurately described the
Keynesian tools but those tools are not
proactive they are reactive so I'll give
you some examples of what a more
progressive proactive perspective would
be a more progressive economic
perspective would say the federal
government should always be bolstering
state unemployment insurance so if they
did that all along and people got more
money from unemployment insurance if
more money was available at the state
level then you wouldn't see this
panicked scramble to do it now but you
wouldn't see the decrease in demand that
you were seeing now because people don't
have money another perspective the
federal government should always be
funding more education and other
government jobs so that when you have a
recession a lot of those jobs just
continue and you avoid having to bail
out as many companies with loans you
avoid having to send as many people
$1,200 checks because a lot of these
government jobs including an education
can simply continue now there's look
that's that's a political perspective
that right-wingers often disagree with
others would say if we had permanent
universal basic income we would obviate
the need for as much of this desperate
spending because people would already be
getting that baseline income from the
government and thus this pandemic
session would be less of an emergency it
would still be one but it would be less
of an emergency if we had here we go now
government-run health care you wouldn't
need Trump negotiating with insurance
companies to waive co-pays on
coronavirus testing or treatment it
would simply be done because the
government is more involved in health
care so that exceeds our time today but
the seat I'm planting is Trump has used
the right tools given the system we have
he's used them in competently but there
are more progressive economic
perspectives which would say if we had
much more government involvement all
along in employment in fiscal policy all
the time it would prevent as much of an
emergency need for that to be done right
now many people don't want more
government involvement and that's a
political debate so I hope that this is
useful to people there's been a
clamoring for more policy stuff like
this I'll produce what the people want
let me know let me know your thoughts on
this particular segment on Twitter at D
Pakman privacy comm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that have
unfortunately more often than we would
like and it's completely free they do
have a paid version with different tiers
where you can create more virtual credit
card numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman